located on the steep hillsides in
chongqing china are the ancient rock
carvings of dasu
[Music]
with more than 60 thousand figures the
dasu carvings are one of the largest and
most spectacular collections of ancient
sculpture work in the world
the carvings date back to the 9th
century featuring imagery from buddhism
taoism and confucianism which highlights
the peaceful coexistence of the three
religions in ancient china
in addition to the religious themes
there are statues of everyday domestic
and farming life from the same period
aesthetically the rock carvings are
animated in appearance and reflect
traditional chinese culture emphasizing
learning from the past
the site wasn't open to visitors until
the 1960s when chinese nationals were
given access
20 years later the carbons were made
available to the general public and
around the turn of the century it was
declared a unesco world heritage site
the organization cited the statute's
aesthetic quality their rich diversity
of subject matter and the light they
shed on everyday life in china during
this period
[Music]